et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
clémentine autain bonjourbonjour
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous avez
plaisait la france intronise seine saint
denis vous êtes candidate aux régionales
en île de france à la tête d'une liste
qui regroupe la france en soumises et le
parti communiste merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour florent buisson
bonjour de la république du centre
florent on commence par l'actualité
nationale on va bien sûr parler des
régionales et de votre programme
clémentine autain mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est emmanuel macron qui a
annoncé hier la fin de l'opération 1
barkan au sahel
il y aura une transformation profonde de
la présence française sur place c'est ce
qu'il a dit c'est une bonne décision
pour vous à la bonne heure j'ai envie de
dire moi je suis très inquiète de
l'embourbement dans cette dans cette
région et surtout je continue à en
appeler un débat parlementaire parce que
pour l'instant la façon dont le
président de la république gère ce type
d'intervention se passe totalement de
débat et de débat national mais aussi de
débats avec le parlement qui date qui
doit avoir son mot à dire
je crois que le temps est venu
maintenant le temps est venu c'est à
dire là avant la fin de la session sur
savoir comment on retire nos troupes
oui oui et ce qu'on y fait et quelle est
notre stratégie c'est un vrai débat
politique y aura un retrait progressif 1
c'est ce qu'il a dit est ce que pour
vous il faut aller plus rapidement la le
retrait progressif va s'étaler sur
plusieurs années est ce qu'il faut aller
rapidement et aboutir plus vite un
retrait total
mais il faut savoir ce qu'on veut il
faire en fait c'est ça le sujet fait
c'est à quoi ça a servi et ce qu'on tire
un bilan de savoir à quoi ça a servi
d'être d'être ainsi présent et ce qu'on
a fait reculer véritablement l'ennemi
que nous cherchons à abattre comment les
populations locales ont pris notre
intervention
tout ça doit être posé sur la table on
va passer à l'autre actualité qui
concerne toujours emmanuel macron mais
sur un tout autre sujet c'est la
condamnation est fière de son agresseur
de la personne qui l'a giflée l'autre
jour dans la drôme 10
mois avec sursis et quatre mois de
prison ferme est ce que c'est une peine
à la hauteur de l'agression pour vous
j'ai du mal à juger une peine je suis
pas juriste je n'ai pas vu le procès je
fais confiance à la justice pour avoir
trouvé une peine qui correspond à l'acte
qu'il a posé ce qui m'inquiète surtout
c'est la dimension politique c'est à
dire le climat social dans lequel nous
nous trouvons avec cette colère sourde
et cette délégitimation des institutions
jusqu'au président de la république qui
peut ainsi se trouver giflé publiquement
ce qui est quand même assez inouï comme
comme scènes que nous que nous avons vu
et cela intervient dans un climat bon
qu'on peut faire remonter toujours un
peu plus mais je dirais que pour moi il
ya eu un moment de bascule avec la
tribune des militaires deux tribus et
d'ailleurs les militaires retraités puis
les militaires par mes qualités voilà
d'actifs ce qui est quand même pas rien
qui intimé l'ordre de ceci ou de cela au
président de la république et au
parlement ensuite ça veut dire vous fait
un lien entre sa tribune et je vais je
vais le jouer je vais arriver à tous les
atouts les liens que je fais si vous
voulez ce que ce que je ressens c'est
qu'on est dans un moment où la violence
monte l'extrême droite monte et il ya un
lien pour moi entre les deux je rappelle
que la personne qui a giflé le président
de la république l'a fait en criant un
slogan royalistes donc et que la
personne avec qui il est et on a trouvé
chez lui le mein kampf
donc c'est que c'est quand même pas rien
quand suite donc je c'est pour ça que je
reviens à cette tribune de militaires
parce que et aussi à cette manifestation
de policiers provoquant l'assemblée
nationale avec des mots d'ordre anti
constitutionnel puis cette vidéo que
nous avons vu deux papas sitôt qui est
un appel au meurtre d'une violence quand
même moi j'ai pas réussi à dire jusqu'au
bout de la vidéo je le dis sincèrement
je trouve ça extrêmement extrêmement
violent donc quand même des appels au
meurtre
donc il ya une ambiance si vous voulez
général ou une extrême droite violence
violentes se sent pousser des ailes et
je ne crois pas que le gouvernement
c'est à dire le pouvoir politique prenne
la mesure de la défiance est d'ailleurs
non seulement là
son du président de la république qui a
cherché finalement à banaliser ce qui
était arrivé avec la gifle d'une
certaine manière enfin c'est à dire que
il a pas vraiment banalisé et non mais
il n'en a pas il en a parlé et il n'a
pas eu n'en a pas rajouté banalisée
j'exagère je retire le mot volontiers et
oui ce que j'arrive n'a pas solenniser
n'a pas il n'a pas dit à quel point
c'était un acte moi je le crois grave
il n'a pas fait ça et dès le lendemain
ou le surlendemain
qu'importe lendemain il décide que il
faut porter le faire maintenant sur
l'immigration moi je dis que là comme il
faut vraiment que ça s'arrête c'est à
dire que on avait beaucoup avaient voté
pour le président de la république l'a
et la république en marche pour être un
rempart à l'extrême droite
et moi je constate juste vous mélangez
les sujets c'est à vous mélangez la
réunion qu'il a eue sur l'immigration à
l'elysée hier avant-hier avec avec
l'agression du président a rappelé jeudi
que le président de la république est
agressé dans un contexte de montée de
l'extrême droite
d'accord et que c'est ce contexte
violent d'une extrême droite qui se sent
pousser des ailes qui est par ailleurs
banalisée sur les plateaux de télévision
pendant qu'on dit c'est qu'on pèse et on
soupèse les mots de jean luc mélenchon
on ne voit rien de cette offensive et de
cette menace pour la république je pèse
mes mots cette menace pour la république
et moi il me semble que c'est une faute
après tout ce qui s'est passé je sais
c'est pour ça que je remonte la tribune
des militaires et au climat général dans
lequel justement madame autun pardonnez
moi de vous couper entendu que les mâles
du climat général ces derniers jours est
ressorti une vidéo de février 2020 vous
l'avez certainement peut-être sur ces
news certainement dans d'autres médias
ou grimée avec d'autres élus la fosse
insoumise vous minier en dansant le faux
passage à tabac d'un d'infos emmanuel
macron
est-ce que ça ça ne participe pas aussi
à ce climat de violence politique
quelques pas est ce que ça ne banalise
pas puisque à utiliser ce terme
oui j'ai vu que c'était quasiment mis
sur le même pied que papa sitôt fin
c'est complètement délirant
parce que quand vous regardez la scène
on chante c'est assez léger c'est drôle
c'est des femmes dont on ne peut pas
dire que ya une distinction que c'est
drôle après on peut considérer que
chacun non mais cela oui si vous voulez
7h 6h ça je peux entendre ça je peux
entendre que l'humour est peut-être
prime différemment d'un endroit où d'un
autre aujourd'hui pour regretter cette
sage mondiale est normal de faire ça
c'est toujours difficile de refaire sur
difficile de refaire l'histoire
voilà ça a été fait c'est pas ces
attaques ainsi une association qui a
proposé ce chant et cette mise en scène
on a des gants mapa
je ne trouve pas que ce soit une scène
de violence en fait je trouve frustrant
que c'est une parodie comme et/ou par
les maîtres l'image est ce que ça oui
mais je ne tarde pas cette semaine ce
que je ne trouverai cette scène violente
d'accord en fait ça que je veux dire
voilà est-ce qu'on voudrait aujourd'hui
est ce qu on leur ferait aujourd'hui est
ce que on n'a pas besoin toutes et tous
de faire particulièrement attention dans
ce climat moi je suis pour qu'on n'en
rajoute pas du tout dans la violence ni
dans les mots ni dans les dents les
fondeurs pense que cette violence là
allait bien sûr d'ailleurs bien sûr
qu'on la sent mais l'avion juste après
l'hégire désaccord avec le président de
la république qui danse dans la façon
dont tillon deux-tiers répond à ce qui
se passe dit c'est insupportable parce
que il n'y a pas de violence de la part
du gouvernement et voyait la violence
aussi faux faux faux consentants moi
j'estime que la politique du
gouvernement c'est de la violence
sociale c'est de l'autoritarisme lol
vous comprenez bien le sens de la
question fut ce que vous avez fait un
symbole mais je sais comme un corps
raquel garrido match est en train de
vous parler
oui je en train de vous parler de la
réalité la politique d' emmanuel macron
c'est autre chose qu'un symbole c'est
une réalité
de la folie qui fait passer en termes de
violence vis-à-vis des gilet jaune c'est
pas des symboles c'est pas de la mise en
scène c'est des gens qui ont perdu un
oeil
c'est des gens qui ont été menacés et
avec une disproportion dans la
répression policière donc je vous parle
pas de symboles je vous parle de la
réalité donc quand le président de la
république nous dit y'a pas de volume
violence du gouvernement
il ya une violence du gouvernement donc
j'estime que la violence du gouvernement
entretient aussi ce climat et j'entends
dans violence aussi violence sociale
violence violence concrète avec des
violences policières tels qu'on les a
vus de l'arbitraire dans les décisions
politiques et de la violence sociale
contestée par les deux jours après celle
entre guillemets l'élite politique ou
politico médiatique que en tant qu'élite
personnes on voit beaucoup à la
télévision
vous ne vous sentez pas investi d'une
mission un peu peut-être autre presque
d'exemplarité debian c'était de tomber
dans ce type de bien sûr bien sûr et je
le leur dis volontiers moi j'ai pas de
problème à dire qu'il est dans notre
expression et dans les actes que nous
posons
moi je crois qu'il faut qu'on ait fait
nous contribuions à élever le débat
démocratique le débat d'idées et à
abaisser le niveau de violence dont pas
je vous dis très tranquillement jeunesse
en arrière c'est plutôt mon profil
aujourd'hui vous le referiez pas après
la gifle du président de la république
on fret en ferait en effet très très
attention mais je ne le conteste et même
je suis très en colère de la façon en
particulier ça m'a été rapporté sur six
news ou en fait au lendemain où il n'y a
pas pas si tôt et où il ya la gym du
président de la république dont eric
zemmour vous auriez pu aussi me dire sa
légitimé par eric zemmour qui nous dit
oui c'est quelque part c'est légitime
c'est légitime mais on passe en boucle
ces images qui sont des images je suis
désolé mais pas très violente quand même
parfaitement parodique les attaques
contre le président oui mais le
président de la république
part d'élus de la nation j'entends bien
j'entends bien j'entends bien j'entends
bien mais des élus de la nation qui
apportait le soutien à une mobilisation
sociale
c'est ce qui se passe et en l'occurrence
féministe et dans la culture féministe
pardonnez-moi mais le pacifisme c'est
quand même quelque chose de très très
fondateur vous savez quand même qu'on a
mené une révolution pour l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes où nous avons
réussi à faire aucun mort du côté des
oppresseurs donc comme mouvement
pacifique vous allez quand même trouvé
difficilement mieux que le moment fait
mise donc moi j'ai cette culture et je
suis pour abaisser en niveau 1 on est en
effet ça mais la responsabilité du
gouvernement est forte et elle est forte
c'est pour ça vous me disiez quel est le
lien avec l'immigration
c'est que je pense que nous ne voyons
rien aujourd'hui et j'insiste de du
tapis rouge qui est fait à l'extrême
droite de la banalisation de l'extrême
droite et on focalise si vous voulez les
les attaques ou les où les menaces
potentielles sur complètement ailleurs
de ce qu'est la menace aujourd'hui
tangible profonde pour notre pays c'est
à dire une extrême droite qui est
puissante et qui a fini par gangréné les
thématiques qui sont mises en avant et
la façon de les traiter
on va parler des violences faites aux
femmes oui vous avez proposé au
gouvernement d'investir un milliard
d'euros dans la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes au delà du
symbole que représente ce chiffre qu'est
ce qu'il englobe précisément ah ben moi
je vous dire l inverse un c'est que pour
moi le symbole c'est les mesures qu'on a
depuis quatre ans prises par le
gouvernement fin c'est incroyable il ya
eu un grenelle
non mais attendez il ya eu un grand les
mots qui sont inflationnistes un
grenelle ensuite y avait la loi on
allait voir ce qu'on allait voir
j'étais j'ai fait tous les bas
parlementaire sur cette loi c'était au
début du quinquennat la première à la
fin la première année ça c'est le
gouvernement vous qu'est ce que vous
proposez entraîné jeu mais je veux dans
ce milliard d'euros ya quatre misérables
quatre misérables article ben voilà avec
des annonces qui sont des annonces qui
ne coûte pas un centime
donc pour moi un milliard c'est investir
dans la formation des policiers des
magistrats des personnels de santé
c'est investir dans le mouvement
associatif qui accompagne les victimes
c'est investir dans du logement
d'urgence et pas simplement du logement
aussi pérenne pour les femmes victimes
de violence parce que vous savez que ce
que nous a dit le
récent rapport c'est que seulement une
femme sur dix est victime de violences
conjugales trouve une solution pour se
reloger
donc moi je veux bien toutes les
nouvelles mesures de droit si vous
voulez qui coûte pas un centime et qui
risquent très peu d'être aussi renforcer
les moyens de lutte contre les violences
conjugales les mesures du gouvernement
très très insuffisamment je ne dis pas
que celles qui sont prises je suis en
désaccord globalement je suis d'accord
avec ce qui est fait je vous dis que
c'est vous reconnaissez que des choses
ont été faites depuis début juin mais de
grâce vous avez vu le mouvement mis tous
vous croyez que le gouvernement peut
laisser le mouvement mis tout comme ça
et puis dire oh ben non on fait rien du
tout merci au revoir on passe à autre
chose non le gouvernement a été
contraint d'agir mais j'estime que ce
qu'il a fait est très très très très en
deçà mais vraiment et je peux pas le
dire très en deçà et le milliard nous
l'avons réclamé à corps et à cris dans
la rue voyez le niveau de violence même
vous dire autre chose
le niveau de violence qu'on a
aujourd'hui dans la société sourde
c'est aussi lié au fait qu' il n'y a pas
d' écoute de ce qui se passe dans la
société d'avoir l'impression qu'on
manifeste sa marche pas on a des
revendications syndicales on nous dit au
revoir le parlement décide quelque chose
merci non le peuple français vote le non
au traité constitutionnel en signe les
traités et donc ancenis par où est ce
que les rouages de la démocratie peuvent
être pris au sérieux et pris en
conjuguant sort sur ce sujet toujours
les procureurs de la république sont
aussi montés au créneau 1 sur la
question des violences conjugales
cette fois réclamant des moyens là
encore avec la création d'un poste dédié
dans chaque parquet
c'est très concret pour le coup est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec cela est-ce
qu'il faut aussi des juristes
spécialisés dans chaque parc est capable
de suivre les affaires en cours
oui sont de plus en plus nombreux mais
il me semble que ça va dans le bon sens
oui je combats parce que les violences
conjugales en particulier ce sont des
mécanismes qui ont des logiques prêt
spécifique il faut être particulièrement
fort mais alors idéalement j'aimerais
mieux que tout le monde soit bien formés
on n'est pas besoin de jules ii voyez ce
que je veux dire une forme de
juridiction particulière mais ce qui est
vrai c'est que il faut connaître les
moyens finalement les moyens
or la république c'est à dire que parce
que le problème des violences faites aux
femmes et du traitement judiciaire elle
est souvent lié au fait que de toute
façon et un débordement un mot là il ya
une saturation qui a pas suffisamment de
moyens pour la justice en général et
ornements et sahil est resté de résorber
avec une augmentation de la vitesse
oui oui mais enfin bon il ya du travail
il faut prioriser c'est ça sur cette
question là qui est déterminé comme
étant la priorité numéro un en matière
de bruit de justice par le gouvernement
c'est en tout cas ce qu'ils disent oui
c'est ce qu'ils disent 1 parce que c'est
aussi une pris une grande priorité
nationale et j'ai pas vu pour l'instant
les moyens encore une fois qu'ils paient
qui permettent de répondre véritablement
la question ça le sujet et justement
dernière question florent croit toujours
qu'on va changer la loi modifiée la loi
mais pas ce n'est pas donné davantage de
moyens au tri-nations ça va faire le
lien avec votre programme et je ne
manquerai dans ma ville à orléans un
immeuble doit ouvrir pour accueillir
temporairement les femmes victimes de
violence jusqu'à la dernière mandature
la ville investit 16 cents mille euros
par an sur cette question est ce que les
villes les collectivités doivent
participer davantage emplettes mans a
complètement moi je propose en
ile-de-france déjà des maisons des
franciliennes que j'aimerais construire
justement avec les collectivités les
mairies les départements pour que en
proximité si vous voulez vous puissiez
vous rendre dans un espace avec des
bénévoles et des personnels associatifs
potentiellement aussi des agents publics
et que là ce soit la première porte
d'entrée
si vous voulez la première porte
d'entrée ou des femmes peuvent venir
parler de violence mais pas seulement
s'appelle de contraception et
d'avortement ça peut être de harcèlement
dans les transports ça peut être de 2,2
voilà de sexisme d'orientation de
problèmes au travail bref je pense qu'on
a besoin de ces lieux de maisons des
franciliennes par ailleurs en ile de
france c'est c'est terrible parce que
valérie pécresse a divisé par deux et
demi le budget global dédié au logement
en ile de france
donc après moi je veux bien qu'on
priorise mais on est dans un registre en
question
on n'a pas vraiment trouvé ces chiffres
divisés par deux et demi
oui où vous les avez pas trouvé sur le
signe du conseil régional d'île de
france val ile de france qui va vous
expliquer ça comme ça rien venir un
budget qui est à peu près équivalent le
rassurer bref vous allez avoir un check
news donc je pense qu'il va sortir dans
la journée ou notamment céline malaisé
qui est la chef de file des communistes
sur la liste pouvoir vivre en ile de
france que je conduis et qui a travaillé
ce sujet sur toute la mandature parce
qu'elle est présidente du groupe front
de gauche et je peux vous assurer qu'on
m'a peut-être pas faire le débat chiffre
est ici parce que c'est très pénible
pour les téléspectateurs
mais je veux juste leur dire que et dont
compréhension mais est-ce parce que
quand on y va louer des logements et et
équivalents bien sûr du bien cela
mandature dans les rues y menant aux
mécènes famille ou de ses fonds de
déchets dont ils pâtissent chiffres
cachés mais je vous assure que c'est
complètement faux justement puisqu'on
parlait des violences faites aux femmes
un mot sur la sécurité ça fait pas
partie des compétences des régions la
sécurité on va le dire très clairement
sauf dans les décors nous en parlons à
chaque fois non mais non parce que genia
quade il ya quand même quelque chose
dans votre programme sur la sur la
sécurité dans les transports vous voulez
réorienter les budgets de surveillance
des franciliens vers le renforcement
humains pour assurer une présence
continue dans les transports ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'ils aient plus
d'humains voyez valérie pécresse fait
toujours le choix des caméras de
surveillance c'est vrai pour les
transports et c'est vrai paul est listé
d'ailleurs elle a même investi vous avez
vous vu dans des caméras pour la
reconnaissance faciale alors que le
droit lui même n'est pas encore certain
donc enfin je veux dire en termes de
l'actuelle a aussi augmenté là aussi la
présence humaine dans les transports et
les anglais c'est la ratp de le faire
damman mais bien sur balles et a aussi
fait son effet mais enfin écoutez
valérie pécresse est connu pour son
austérité budgétaire et pour avoir
diminué partout la présence des services
publics et des humains dans les dents
les dans les lycées c'est terrifiant et
alors elle peut toujours se cacher
derrière ile-de-france mobilité si vous
voulez et dire j'ai demandé mais la
réalité de la politique de valérie
pécresse le syndic de 150 personnes
supplémentaires chasser sur les terres
dans l'être bien sûr bien sûr alors
peut-être sur la sécurité elle peut
faire vaguement un effort mais en terme
de présence humaine en termes de
présence humaine ça n'est pas du tout ça
ça un sac à main sont son parti pris et
je vais vous dire puisque vous aimez
bien les lignes budgétaires de la région
allait voir deux lignes très
intéressante qui concerne la prévention
vous avez deux lignes l'une pour les
écoles et une pour la médiation mais
pour la médiation à chaque fois et la
prévention de casser des lignes de
prévention qui sont plutôt de
compétences régionales et là vous avez 3
millions qui ont été directement
supprimés par valérie pécresse
donc vous êtes sur un renforcement
humains pour assurer la sécurité on est
pas on n'est pas ce n'est pas notre
compétence nous pouvons faire des choses
notamment en matière de prévention et
valérie pécresse veut elle ne pas
s'occuper de prévention et être
uniquement dans la surveillance
généralisée et dans la répression
c'est un vrai désaccord de fond voilà
les franciliennes et franciliens ont
deux bulletins de vote qui ont deux
cohérence politique différente c'est bon
pour la démocratie ça puisqu'on parle
des transports on va parler de la
gratuité dans les transports c'est un
sujet qui intéresse aussi beaucoup les
franciliens vous la gratuité dans les
transports vous voulez la limiter aux
moins de 25 ans ça veut dire que la
gratuité totale pour vous des transports
c'est une utopie c'est pas réaliste à
court terme je n'y suis pas favorable
j'y suis favorable à long terme c'est
important de le dire c'est à dire que
l'horizon gratuite et je le partage et
ma famille politique s'est toujours
battu d'ailleurs pour saler l'at-il du
coup cet horizon parler de long terme
moi je peux dire ce que je ferai comme
présidente de région sur la mandature
donc sur la mandature je suis favorable
à ce qu'on ait une gratuité pour les
moins de 25 ans et une gratuité pour
tous les bénéficiaires des minima
sociaux
puis au cours de la mandature ça s'est
immédiatement mais au cours de la
mandature j'aimerais qu'on puisse
également ouvrir la gratuité pour les
personnes retraitées sous conditions de
ressources
voilà ça c'est ce qu'on propose dans ce
monde là et pourquoi parce que nous
voulons qu'il reste suffisamment de
moyens financiers pour aller abondé dans
ce qui est pour nous notre priorité
c'est les transports du quotidien leur
modernisation et leur développement
je veux qu'on modernise les rer b c et d
urgemment
je veux qu'on soit capable de donner
plus de flop de bus en grande couronne
c'est très important je veux qu'on
investisse aussi dans un plan vélo un
pour les pour les transports 1 cc c'est
beaucoup d'argent j'aimerais que on
arrive sur dix ans à un peu au delà de
ma mandature mais à mettre deux
milliards sur la table ce avec le vélo
c'est le transport le moins sûr
transports doux qui est bon pour la
santé etc donc il faut des kilomètres de
pistes sécurisées et je m'y engage
voilà je veux aussi qu'on ait un un
métro circulaire autour de paris pour y
compris désengorger cette fameuse ligne
13 on n'en peut plus et puis développer
les transports banlieue banlieue
représente quoi en terme
d'investissement assez énorme
donc c'est pas que la région c'est qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que tout ça
suppose des négociations très serrées
avec l'état on a le supermétro en là les
problèmes aussi ce qui vous fait dire
qu'ils vont vous aider du coup abba est
la volonté politique et le suffrage
voilà c'est la légitimité que j'aurais
on va on va parler d'économie de
développement économique puisque ça pour
le coup c'est une compétence majeure de
la région alors dans votre programme il
ya beaucoup de choses sur l'économie
sociale et solidaire vous demander à
l'état d'interdire les licenciements
boursiers il ya aussi beaucoup de choses
pour conditionner les aides aux
entreprises à des critères sociaux et
des critères environnementaux
qu'est ce que vous faites concrètement
pour aider aujourd'hui les entreprises
franciliennes et l'économie francilienne
qui a été très fortement à partir
impacté par la crise sanitaire par la
crise économique
là vous parlez des entreprises voilà
alors d'abord vous l'avez compris ce que
je veux c'est qu'on contribue à modifier
à réorienter l'économie francilienne
c'est ce que j'appelle la bifurcation
sociale et écologique pour qu'elle
corresponde davantage la satisfaction
des besoins des habitants plus qu'autre
plutôt que de satisfaire les besoins du
capital de s'accroître et d'être dans
une logique de financiarisation de
l'économie
ça c'est un grand désaccord que j'ai
avec valérie pécresse qui choisit
toujours l'attractivité et la
compétitivité sur les besoins des
habitants je prends un exemple qui va
vraiment changer la donne
valérie pécresse a donné il ya quinzaine
de jours un million d'euros à renault
qui vient d'annoncer la suppression de
2400 postes ce million d'euros comme les
20 millions d'euros qui ont été donnés
sur la mandature aux entreprises du cac
40 je veux les réinvestir dans le fond
de résilience que je veux pérenniser
pour justement des entreprises plus
petites moyennes dans l'économie sociale
et solidaire je veux qu'on est un fonds
d'investissement pour soutenir et je
propose un mécanisme est peut-être un
peu plus complexe mais que je vais vous
dire de chaque francilien
j'aimerais que nous créions un fonds
avec la région et d'autres partenaires
qui permettent d'engranger des milliards
d'euros et ses milliards d'euros ont les
réinjecte dans l'économie par le biais
de chèques qui fonctionne un peu comme
des tickets restaurant savez un ticket
restaurant on abonde donc là on aurait
un ticket bon d'achat de 100 euros
on a mis 80 et le fonds abondé par la
région a mis 20 est la contrepartie
c'est que c'est fléché et c'est fléché
vers des commerces de proximité qui
doivent se battre contre les commerces
contre les grands groupes de type hyper
marchés etc
c'est quand même une concurrence qui est
déloyal donc je veux qu'on les soutienne
je veux qu'on soutienne l'artisanat je
veux qu'on soutienne l'économie sociale
et culture et et sociale et solidaire et
que nous investissions dans le sport et
la culture
vous savez que je propose que nous
compensions le prix de la licence pour
les clubs sportifs pour qu'elle soit
cette année à 10 euros point à la ligne
qu'on n'aille pas au delà donc on va
compenser donc voilà le soutien que je
veux apporter à l'économie francilienne
qui est un soutien pour tenir le choc
mais qui est un soutien aussi pour
redéployer différemment notre économie
et qu'elle cherche véritablement à
satisfaire les besoins
je vais vous dire un mot c'est que au
fond ce que je crois c'est qu'au xxième
siècle la grande question économique et
social ces nos besoins de quoi
avons-nous véritablement besoin et la
crise nous a aidé les besoins essentiels
des besoins superflus et on voit bien
que le monde marchand sans arrêt vous
suscite des besoins vous avez à peine
acheter un truc que déjà il est plus
moderne qu'il faut acheter le suivant
qui va acheter sur et donc
l'investissement aussi dans un service
public de la réparation que je propose
c'est une manière de lutter contre ce
délire consumériste et je veux que les
consommateurs aient les moyens de
devenir acteurs de leur consommation en
question politique pour finir clémentine
autain puisqu'il paraît difficile pour
la gauche 2 bat valérie pécresse sans
alliance
sa cible sans alliance annonçant
alliance non il faut lier donc il faut
l'alliance anne hidalgo cette semaine
elle a dit que les propos tenus par jean
luc mélenchon ne permettent pas de se
réunir est ce que ça ça vaut aussi pour
les régionales ou est-ce qu'une alliance
avec audrey pulvar est possible
d'imaginer que vous avez entendu
l'intégralité de l'interview d'anne
hidalgo comme je lé fais aussi est
précisément je les trouvais très
prudente
et pour cause parce que en ile de france
nous allons vers une alliance à
l'évidence qu'il y aura cette alliance
je crois je le veux et je le crois avec
les trois avec julien bayou même et
audrey le jeu les dix dès la rien celui
qui est arrivé en tête c'est la seule la
réaction c'est la règle mais moi je lui
ai dit dès le mois de novembre si je
suis en tête je mettrai toute mon
énergie pour réussir cette alliance je
la crois possible et je vais vous dire
je la crois très dynamique parce qu'elle
n'est pas factice quand vous écoutez ce
que nous disons on vous recommande de
l'avoir fait au premier tour parce que
nous avons des profils et des
différences politiques ça vous échappe
pas oui quand vous mais le voulez bien
écouter julien bayou audrey pulvar ya
quand même par les alliances qui n'est
pas factice donc non ça c'est facile
c'est le premier bien sûr mais je pense
qu'au second tour nous aurons une baisse
de rassemblement qui n'est pas
artificielle qui a qui a de solides
fondements pour rediriger la région pour
autant au premier tour c'est c'est aussi
correct de demander aux électeurs et aux
électrices de trancher entre différentes
familles politiques et aussi entre
différents profils pour présider la
région
je crois que j'incarne le profil le plus
solide le plus cohérent face à valérie
pécresse et je crois aussi plus
profondément que notre liste est celle
qui peut créer la dynamique populaire de
second tour qui nous permet de
l'emporter parce que au second tour on
voit bien valérie pécresse qui n'a pas
d'alliés est au premier tour de façon
impressionnante au delà 30 et autour de
30 et nous à trois on arrive aussi au
second tour autour de 30
donc faut arrêter vraiment de passer la
barre des 10 si tout le monde passe un
peu non il suffit qu'un passe la barre
des 10 il suffit qu'un pas gérard des
dix et on fusionne voilà donc si et dans
ce cas là vous avez deux blocs autour de
donc cette élection n'est pas joué c'est
faux de raconter qu'elle est joué or si
je suis en tête je crois que nous
pouvons créer un sursaut de mobilisation
notamment dans les quartiers populaires
et que c'est ça qui peut nous permettre
de l'emporter
un dernier mot très rapidement sur ce
qu'a dit arnaud montebourg hier dans le
parisien vous l'avez sans doute lui un
jean luc mélenchon fait prendre au débat
public des allures condamnable
mélenchonisme est devenu un sectarisme
il a pu être une solution 2017 il est
devenu blocage de la gauche qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ça je peux je sais
pas quoi dire
arnaud montebourg qui qui qui revient
pour rassembler tout en ayant un propos
à ces diviseurs écouter tout ça est très
compliqué je vais vous dire le fond de
ma pensée
pour l'instant je suis concentré sur
élections régionales et je reviens une
fois l'élection régionale passé et je
vous dis mon sentiment général sur la
présidentielle qui vient mais une chose
après l'autre
allez l'engagement est tenu en or sera
prélève je la remercie qu elle inclinée
sans merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité
[Musique]